nicolas sarkozy a entamé cet après-midi
un voyage délicat en russie délicat car
c'est une épreuve de vérité
pendant la campagne le président de la
république avait souhaité un changement
de ton vis-à-vis du régime autoritaire
de vladimir poutine sur la question des
droits de l'homme notamment mais on sait
aussi que la russie est un partenaire
incontournable pour la france reportage
à moscou laurent boussier xavier luizet
l'a dit mir poutine qui emmène nicolas
sarkozy en 4 4 pour une visite expresse
que sa datcha l'image affichée d'une
certaine complicité
et pourtant en langage diplomatique on
appelle ça une visite délicate
il y évidemment l'accueil les sourires
et les poignées de main et un plaisir de
venir
mais pour cette première visite en
russie du président sarkozy il ya aussi
les sujets qui divisent le nucléaire
iranien à l'indépendance du kosovo les
droits de l'homme l'utilisation par la
russie de la revue gaz souvent critique
nicolas sarkozy dit vouloir établir ici
un dialogue franc et ferme j'ai pu
apprécier la fermeté de bouffon budget
de ce point de vue je continue à dire
qu'on peut se comprendre parce que ses
convictions j'en ai aussi je ferai tout
pour répondre à toutes vos questions et
expliquer notre position sur n'importe
quel sujet jusqu'à demain soir les deux
présidents qui vont se voir au moins
trois fois auront le temps de confronter
leurs convictions la russie qui reste un
partenaire stratégique dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme dans la coopération
dans les échanges commerciaux entend
bien avoir des éclaircissements sur
cette nouvelle attitude de la france
bonsoir laurent bousses